but it seems reasonable to me that the
goal of the people that are like in the
wef and stuff like that um and the UN
stuff the goal is to do a soft Landing
with the United States as China Rises
and the intent is in this is to keep the
whole world out of world war three but
if they can have a soft landing and
lower the US's living standards in a way
that doesn't cause too much chaos in the
United States and also at the same time
support China so they can raise their
their level of of influence and stuff
and manage that without having the US
and trying to go to war that I think is
the goal because the the the Chinese
model in my opinion is what the people
like the wef and stuff was what they
want to Institute in the west because
they have essentially ultimate control
over the population